the long-awaited clash of the titans is
finally here
godzilla vs kong has all the kaijuan
kaiju action audiences love
as well as a few fun easter eggs here
are the best ones you might have missed
spoilers ahead when godzilla vs kong
starts audiences are treated to king
kong's morning routine
he wakes up strolls through a river
washes his face and throws a tree at the
sun
you know normal giant gorilla antics
except it turns out king kong is stuck
in a monarch containment outpost
and he just skewered a section of its
holographic ceiling specifically sector
7g
simpson's fans know that homer simpson
works in sector 7g of the springfield
nuclear power plant and king kong of
course fights a walking nuclear lizard
in the movie
it's my problem
is now being isolated godzilla and king
kong first crossed paths in 1962
this was when the godzilla films were
goofier and campier essentially the
adam west batman era of godzilla that's
why the original king kong vs godzilla
has its share of goofy moments
the film includes one moment that
survived in meme form and was referenced
in godzilla vs kong
around the halfway mark of the movie
godzilla attacks a floating convoy of
ships carrying king kong to trick
godzilla into thinking they're dead the
crew cuts power which leaves them in a
predicament they can't continue
ferrying kong to antarctica without
moving and they can't move without
alerting godzilla
so they make the only reasonable choice
fly the rest of the way by helicopter
while carrying king kong in an oversized
net while not a one-to-one translation
this scene references the prelude to the
1962 king kong vs godzilla's mount fuji
scene where the army airlifts king kong
and basically drops him on godzilla's
head
and that film kong is strung up to
several balloons and ferried along by
helicopters
godzilla vs kong's rendition is
basically a modern upgrade to the
classic scene
many tv shows movies and plays feature a
literary device known as chekhov's gun
if the opening act prominently displays
a gun someone will shoot it during or
before the final act
godzilla vs kong's chekhov's gun comes
in the form of conspiracy theorist
bernie hayes alcohol
flask since the film draws attention to
the flask audiences know he will either
drink it or use it to save the day
but this chekhov's flask and its
contents also play double duty as an
easter egg when josh asks bernie what's
in the flask bernie says it is filled
with katsunari single malt whiskey
that's a very specific name for a
chekhov's gun did legendary pictures
make a deal with a whiskey manufacturer
to make bernie in his flask act as a
trojan
product placement no instead the name
most likely honors godzilla
film suit actor kazunari mori who played
mechagodzilla in 1974's godzilla vs
mechagodzilla so not only did the flask
and its contents tease how the main
villain will be defeated
its fictional brand name teases the
identity of said villain sure
the name of the whiskey isn't exactly
the same as the name of the original
mecha godzilla actor but it feels too
similar to just be a coincidence
since the godzilla franchise has been
around since 1954 the series has been
through
several ups and downs some more infamous
than others to godzilla fans it's
difficult to get more infamous than
north america's first attempt at
creating a godzilla film
that movie now wears a permanent
bullseye that godzilla vs kong's
creators gladly shot at
possibly during godzilla vs kong king
kong is trapped on a ship in the tasman
sea with miles of water in every
direction
he can't move but more importantly he
can't hunt for food
to mangle an old phrase what does a 158
ton gorilla eat
whatever he wants but since he's in the
middle of the ocean he'll just have to
settle for fish
a lot of fish one of the most frequently
derided scenes in the 1998 godzilla
movie is when the army tries to bait
godzilla out with fish
a big pile of fish
so kong's seafood feast in godzilla
versus kong is a fun callback to the
1998 box office disappointment
and finally though director adam wingard
formally crowns a winner in godzilla vs
kong the way the original matchup movie
didn't
he clearly still has love for the
original king kong vs godzilla
since the ending shots are very similar
in king kong vs godzilla kong swims away
as tiny humans watch from the shore
in godzilla vs kong it's godzilla who
swims away in a clear homage to the
original
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one